j'ai eu à essuyer ce genre de péripéties
au cours de ma carrière et notamment
j'ai été désinvité d'un colloque en
allemagne par des collègues sociologue
qui n'ont pas souhaité que je fasse une
des conférences plénières parce que j'ai
été identifiés comme antisémite et
partisane de bds de dbd
désinvestissement sanctions contre
contre l'état d'israël
donc ce sont des choses qui se passent
dans le secret des des conversations je
n'ai jamais rendu public parce que je ne
voulais pas mettre en difficulté les
deux collègues qui m'avait invitée et
qui ont subi des pressions de leurs
milieux académiques en allemagne donc ce
sont des choses qui arrivent
régulièrement en fait sont la question
est de savoir si et là en l'occurrence
effectivement ça fait partie des sujets
qui fâchent
de quoi va-t-on parler donc moi ce qui
m'inquiète en fait c'est la difficulté
qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui à établir
les les espaces d'une controverse et
d'une polémique qui soit fructueuse pour
tous la capacité à admettre que des
points de vue puissent s'exprimer qui
heurte les sensibilités et notamment
lorsque ses sensibilités
elle renvoie en fait à un point de vue
qui a été dominant qui a toujours été
très installé qui a pu prospérer en tout
confort et en toute tranquillité et puis
qui se voit contesté par de nouvelles
voies par de nouvelles interprétations
et pour ma part moi ce à partir de quoi
je réfléchis à ces questions là c'est
les questions d'islamophobie c'est les
questions des colonials c'est les
questions de la remise en cause la
suprématie blanche et de la supériorité
occidentale et dans ce domaine là aussi
énormément de paroles qui sont réduites
au silence
[Musique]